five three
two one release release release
clean release well we are one step
closer to making space
travel commercially available today sir
richard branson and his virgin galactic
team
launched into space for a flight test
and to showcase the private astronaut
experience kate houston spoke to a las
vegas man who will be first in line once
commercial flights open up
she joins us live in the newsroom with
more kate
sasha this is a new type of space race
where private companies are working to
bring tourists up to the stars
now here behind me you can see some
footage from that launch earlier this
morning and for one local man
this is bringing him one step closer to
fulfilling a lifelong dream
i was interested in rockets from the
beginning
since childhood ken baxter has wanted to
go to space
it's going to be very exciting to be
able to go down and go up to outer space
look back at the earth i can't wait in
2004 baxter bought the first civilian
ticket for 200 thousand dollars
in 2012 eight news now checked in with
baxter when virgin galactic was
initially granted an experimental launch
permit
excitement of going to outer space is
really second to none
now following virgin galactic's
successful flight on sunday
unity is pointed directly up and heading
to space that dream
is now inching closer it's going to be
so exciting you will
not believe it i can't wait for it let's
get it done
and let's see all the other people
coming to get on the team here
the unity 22 mission was the first to
carry a full crew
including pilots specialists and virgin
founder sir richard branson
to all you kids down there i was once a
child with a dream
looking up to the stars now
i'm an adult in a spaceship the team was
launched to an altitude of about 50
miles that is a full duration burn folks
we are headed to space
where they experienced weightlessness
and incredible views of earth
two more test flights are scheduled
before virgin galactic expects to launch
commercial services next year and usher
in the era of space tourism
for the next generation of dreamers if
we can do
this just imagine what you can do
this historic flight is happening just
days before another private company
launches into space fellow billionaire
jeff bezos plans to launch his blue
origin spaceship
on july 20th back to you